bonsoir dans cette nouvelle édition du 7
8 ce soir nous allons parler santé
notamment cet appel du corps médical à
l'encontre des porteurs du vih des
porteurs dit invisible nous en parlerons
dans quelques instants avec jérôme andré
il sera aussi question d'un opéra en
plein air aïda de verdi jouer ce samedi
soir à buc dans la page
eco car quand il reviendra sur le bilan
de la maison de l'entreprise saint
quentin en yvelines et sur le plan de
sécurisation a signé pour la première
fois par un centre commercial en ile de
france et ça se passe à vélizy mais est
tout d'abord ce qui pourrait faire
jurisprudence en france et ça se passe à
bois d'arcy et oui cela pourrait faire
jurisprudence
un détenu de la maison d'arrêt de bois
d'arcy pourrait sortir d'ici une semaine
en raison de ses conditions de détention
c'est une première la décision en
revient à une juge d'instruction qui a
justement constater les mauvaises
conditions de détention
maître stéphane sebag l'avocat du détenu
a pu se rendre dans la cellule de son
client son client il s'agit d'un
étudiant de rouen incarcéré depuis deux
mois et demi en attente de son jugement
pour recel d'escroquerie précisons que
le jeune homme mesure 1 mètre 95 aulas a
son importance
voici justement le récit de son avocat
des compos recueillis par julie
rechausse forrest vie m² 3 2 kipré pour
trois ans avec 3 ou changent de
personnes
la vitesse il y à des infiltrations
d'eau au mur local et cela dans les
parois l'air rentre également de sorte
que lorsque tu fais des trois il ya un
mois et demi encore et bien nos clients
étaient frigorifiés
il y avait pas tellement exigu que 2
personnes 2
ne pas s'émouvoir enfin il y a une
semaine pour donner
normalement c'est une obligation d'avoir
au moins une chaîne par des non là il a
seulement une très longue poutre est
condamné à être toute la journée
allongée sur son lit et de toutes les
balles font un état de vétusté
incroyable et soit pourront des
conditions comme tu le dit le texte
complètement dégradante et accablement